yes the religious right and the gay
rights movement will eventually come to
the same terms we'll come to terms the
same terms that religious people have
had to come to around gender equality
racial equality we ignore the bullshit
in the Bible about race about slavery we
ignore the bullshit in the Bible about
women we ignore the bullshit in the
Bible about women should be killed on
their wedding night so they're not
virgins that parents were right to
murder their disobedient children
there's all sorts of crazy bullshit in
the Bible that we just ignored that
religious people ignore and we're gonna
have to get there for homosexuality if
we could ignore what the Bible says
about slavery Bible got slavery wrong
something is easy and obvious as slavery
is sam harris wrote in a letter to a
christian nation if the bible got
slavery wrong it's wrong to force
somebody to own another human being
Jesus Sermon on the Mount couldn't spare
a sub clause to say don't own people the
Bible got slavery wrong something is
easy and obvious of moral outrage the
odds of the Bible that something is
complicated is human sexuality wrong
pretty high and what religious people
have to reconcile themselves to is
dropping it dropping ignoring what the
Bible says about gay people the way they
ignore what the Bible says about
polyester and lobster and figs and
shrimp and women